we watched a whole lot of TV this year
maybe too much TV and then we locked
ourselves in a room argued a whole bunch
and ranked the top 10 TV shows of 2016
making our list by the invulnerable skin
of its teeth is Luke Cage this
adaptation of the 1970s blaxploitation
comic book of the same name pays enough
homage to its sometimes embarrassing
roots to keep diehard fans happy and the
fact that featured Marvel's first black
superhero wasn't lost in the show's
creators the authentic feel of the
Harlem setting the soundtrack spanning
70s funk to modern hip hop and The
Fearless references to slavery and
racism changed the game of superhero
depiction on television not to mention
how cool this was
consider this a warning the Americans
has just two seasons left if you haven't
already you need to catch up think of it
as full house with a whole lot more
family drama and if Danny Tanner was a
Russian spy oh and their neighbor works
for the FBI okay so it's not that feel a
good show by any means it's a tense cold
war thriller full of anxiety and emotion
one that covers the professional work of
Russian sleeper agents and the
challenges of raising American children
at home talk about balancing work and
family life hey I know do yourself a
favor and watch this show even though
you already know how the cold war ends
the second season of daredevil may not
have been as strong as its debut but it
had some standout moments and some
standout characters yeah the Punisher
killed a whole lot of people and he made
such a lasting impression that he'll be
getting his own spin-off who doesn't
have their own netflix show a ton of
questions remained at the end of season
2 what the hell was that giant hole in
the ground what happens to Elektra well
Karen still be BFFs with Matt Murdock
and so on but most importantly how long
will we have to wait for season 3 fans
of hbo's silicon valley revel in both
Richard Hendricks successes and failures
especially if those failures end up with
him seeing his doctor who is always
pitching incredibly terrible ideas for
apps during season 3 Richard was
stripped of his CEO title in favor of
action Jack Parker who ultimately wore
out his own welcome home was ousted
himself whether it's Richards
rollercoaster life or Erlich Bachman
terrible ideas that somehow pan out
there's a lot to love about this show in
past season Erlich Bachman mr. Bachman
pleasure to finally meet you I'm I'm a
big fan oh really of what Metamucil will
Pied Piper ever reach its full potential
who knows but it's a lot of fun watching
it flounder
the second season of ash vs. Evil Dead
hit the gas immediately with revved up
chainsaws fully loaded shotguns in even
a puppet it was crammed to the brim with
gore humor and unexpected twists you
honestly never know when and where ash
is going to end up next case in point
this moment when he was pulled through a
corpses rotten anus as long as you can
stomach it ash vs. Evil Dead was a hell
of a good time ludicrously funny and
sick at the same time agents of shield
exists in a realm of small budgets and
big expectations despite being Jan
between numerous superhero show
competitors and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe taking the lead on major
storylines this show didn't run from the
fight in fact we got to see a whole new
take on Ghost Rider and we also had some
magic on the show for the first time
with the inclusion of the dark hold
anyone who loves comics can respect the
brave story adaptations the show made
this season and anyone who just wanted
to see she get blown up can watch this
does the future of technology and social
media trouble you well here's a show
that will only exaggerate those fears
season 3 of black mare continued its
excellent depiction of our darkest
addictions in the digital age looking
for a horror story on the dangers of
virtual and augmented reality or how
about a sharp satire on social media
where we actually dish out star ratings
to each other like we're a bird drivers
there's just one thing to consider when
watching season 3 save San junipero for
the end because it finishes on a happy
note something that never happens on
this show here's the premise patrons pay
forty thousand dollars a day to fulfill
their deepest desires in a western
themed amusement park populated by
robots westworld played with our minds
more than any other show this year who's
a host what year are we in what the hell
is the maze consciousness isn't a
journey upward but a journey inward so
the host can think on their own and that
means trouble for the human race right
sure looks like it but there are still a
ton of unanswered questions we can't
wait for season 2 especially if we get
to see more of that Shogun samurai world
what is this place oh hey look a new
science fiction show on Netflix that
completely plays with our heartstrings
by appealing to our sense of nostalgia
there were monsters superpowers eggo
waffles and a collection of kids riding
their bikes across the city it was like
Goonies meets et meets the creepiest
parts of a nine inch nails video
regardless the show seemed to grip the
nation as we all mourn the death of the
most loyal BFF ever barb we're looking
forward to jumping back into the upside
down next season
Game of Thrones comes in at our hotly
debated number one spot this season
featured some of the best moments in the
history of the show Jon Snow woke up
from his cold long nap the Battle of the
bastards blew our minds and Cersei
returned to power in explosive fashion
murdering a bunch of people while
enjoying a nice glass of wine Plus now
we know why this dude only says the show
is finally free from George RR Martin's
literary shackles and has set itself up
perfectly for the series dramatic
conclusion also can we please see more
of this one he's my king from this day
until his last day so what was your
favorite TV show in 2016 hit us up in
the comments and let us know and if you
want to stay up to date with all of our
entertainment videos be sure to
subscribe to gamespot universe on
YouTube it's gamespot's permanent home
for TV movies and comics as of January
third subscribe now so you never miss a
video